le problème c'est que même arrêté il va
pas faire 10 ans de prison pour avoir le
vélo donc il est déjà en liberté donc il
peut très bien avoir envie de se venger
vous dit qu'il y a un couteau même sans
parler du couteau il peut très bien dire
ça elle est malade mapouka mais elle m'a
balancer je vais venir me venger ou dans
la rue même si sans vous de l'histoire
de vous tuer mais au moins vous tapez ou
pas est-ce que vous avez fait victime de
de chantage et ben les filles qui sont
ils ont fait le traquenard eux-mêmes ces
raisons piégé
c'est quelqu'un qui faisait du chantage
à une sextape enfin une sextape une
photo intime c'est quoi l'histoire bah
c'était une fille avec qui j'avais
j'avais loué des relations épistolet
enfin par écrit sur les réseaux
non j'avais jamais vu parce qu'elle
habitait loin soit disant Orléans de
base voir qu'un jour plus tard
j'ai envoyé une photo intime
c'est-à-dire une photo sous la douche il
faut une photo ouais genre une photo
[Applaudissements]
et du coup elle me elle voulait me
donner rendez-vous mais au dernier
moment il m'a dit je viendrai pas en ce
moment je viendrai pas mais il était si
tu veux pas que je balance ma photo à
tout le monde et elle me réclamait 3500
€ comme ça j'ai été porté plainte j'ai
hésité je mets ce que je peux ou pas
j'étais voir les policiers qui ont
décidé de monter à tractar pour la
choper ils m'ont dit n'y allait pas tout
ça et c'est eux qui sont occupés bon ils
n'ont pas chopé parce que visiblement
elle avait elle avait des doutes elle
s'est barrée avant d'avant d'arriver sur
place mais voilà mais c'est très
dangereux de voir se faire justice
soi-même parce que le franchement lui il
est déjà en liberté quoi et je vous
répondez à ça
je me suis protégée j'ai acheté un petit
un petit truc quand vous êtes arrivés
donc tu as quand même tu flippes un peu
quand même bah je flippe c'est pour ça
j'ai un taser quand je vais au boulot je
vais mon petit Taser dans mes poches que
si cher qu'un vélo
surtout qu'il est il est dans votre
quartier je crois il est assez fier en
fait d'avoir fait le buzz sur les
réseaux
conscient d'avoir fait quelque chose il
le sera pas parce qu'il va avoir trois
jours de je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle rappelle à la loi je pense pas
il a déjà plusieurs condamnations là on
est à la 10 11e condamnation le gamin il
est encore parlé de quatre trottinettes
sur leboncoin il y a que des vélos des
trottinettes des trucs volés
vous savez que c'est c'est interdit
d'avoir
on a pas loin